(audience cheering)
Okay we're back,
I'm sitting here with Serena Williams.
(audience applauds)
I really wanna play you in tennis,
the problem is we don't
have enough room in here to
play an actual tennis match,
Yeah, I was worried
about that.
so we were wondering if you would play me
on the Nintendo Wii Tennis game?
Are you up for it?
(audience cheers)
You wanna do it?
Yeah.
Let's do it,
come on, alright!
(audience applauds)
Let's go, follow me, it's right over here.
It's right here,
Okay.
we're gonna set this up.
Of course I uh,
I like to be dressed
for the occasion, so.
Oh cool.
Whaa! (laughs)
(crowd cheering)
(Conan growls)
(Serena laughs)
(audience cheers)
Oh, my... (laughing)
Yeah, a little a...
Remote controls here somewhere?
(laughs) Like, you're intimidating me.
(laughs) Then why are
you laughing so hard?
(Serena laughs)
(audience laughs)
Alright, I haven't
really done this before,
someone's gonna get us started here,
'cause I don't know what I'm doing.
Does anybody know what we're doing here?
Oh, here's an Aaron.
Buddy are you gonna
show me what I'm doing?
Aah, nice job.
(audience cheers)
[Audience Member] Yeah, Aaron!
[Serena] I'm so bad at this.
[Conan] Aah nice, okay,
who's serving here?
Okay, who's the server?
Uh, you're serving.
I'm serving?
Alright, check it out,
'cause here comes the master!
Ha!
Ah!
(racquet hits)
Oh, (indistinct), whaa,
Yah!
Oh, wait okay I was late, that was late.
(audience cheers)
Okay.
Let's see my forearm here,
let's see my form.
Sorry I (indistinct)
Oh, okay, here we go, Alright again.
Here we go, ha,
Ah!
(racquet hits)
Okay.
(Serena laughs)
(audience cheers)
I don't even know what happened there,
what happened there?
Okay.
I have no idea what happened..
Oh!
(audience laughs)
What happened there?
(Serena laughs)
I'm wearing my outfit from
the "Australian Open".
(Conan laughs)
(audience laughs)
The green, it's so hot, the Nike.
You've been partying too hard.
Okay, here I come again.
Yah!
(racquet hits)
Uh,
okay, whoa, ah!
(racquet hits)
Ah!
Oh, naa!
Yes!
(Conan yells)
(audience cheers)
That was a great shot.
That was uh, you got lucky there,
'cause here I come again!
Wah!
(racquet hits)
Uh!
Oh, okay, hold on, whoa!
(audience cheers)
I think you just killed
some people. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
Oh look at that, nice!
Oh!
Alright, here we go and, haa,
Ah!
(racquet hits)
Uh!
Whoa, backhand, oh!
(racquet hits)
Out.
Oh.
Whoo!
(audience applause)
The hell was that?
(Serena laughs)
[Audience Member] Come on, Conan!
(audience cheers)
Ah!
(racquet hits)
Uh!
Yeah!
(audience cheers)
You know, (chuckles) I can't take it.
You, can't take anymore.
Waa!
(racquet hits)
(audience cheers)
Come on, that was in!
That was in?
You're yelling at Nintendo Wii,
alright that's... (chuckles)
That was so in,
I'm not gonna play this anymore.
(Conan laughs)
All right, well here we
go, here's game point,
here we go, yah!
Ah!
(racquet hits)
(audience cheers)
Aah!
Aww. (chuckles)
(audience applause)
Alright thank you very much.
Thank you. (laughs)
That was fun, that's my dream come true.
Take a break, and come back (indistinct)
Serena Williams everybody!
(audience cheers)